[Musica]
[Applauso]
iniziamo subito da una domanda pillola
blu o pillola rossa ora tutti voi
ricorderete la famosissima scena di
matrix in cui morpheus chiede all'eletto
neo di scegliere tra queste due pillole
pillola blu rimanere nel matrix rimanere
nel sistema lasciare tutto così com'è
rimanere nella menzogna che ci hanno
raccontato
pillola rossa invece la via della verità
uscire dal matrix rompere il sistema
uscir fuori dalla prigione che hanno
costruito per noi vedere quanto è
profonda la tana del bianconiglio dice
morpheus anni o citando ovviamente alice
nel paese delle meraviglie e questa
domanda chiaramente ci riguarda tu cosa
sceglieresti vuoi prendere la pillola
blu vuoi rimanere così come sei vuoi
svegliarti domani mattina tranquillo nel
tuo letto oppure prendi la pillola rossa
oppure hai il coraggio di seguire la
strada della verità anche se questa
verità potrebbe essere più crudele più
terribile di quello che immagini ora
matri crea un film profondamente
filosofico ispirato a tanti filosofi
questa scena è chiaramente ispirata ad
uno dei miti più noti della storia del
pensiero occidentale e cioè il mito
della caverna di platone che vedete qui
rappresentato gli uomini immagina il
filosofo greco vivono in una prigione in
una caverna buia e nel fondo di questa
caverna vedono delle ombre di fronte a
loro proiettate da un fuoco alle loro
spalle che però loro non vedono e li
scambiano per realtà le scambiano per
verità
uno di questi prigionieri riesce a
liberarsi dalle catene riesce a fuggire
dice platone riesce a risalire fuori e
finalmente vede la realtà vede la verità
è a confronto con la luce del sole gli
altri invece gli altri prigionieri
rimangono nella tenebra nelle loro
menzogne
ecco chiaramente sia il film delle
sorelle wacko's chi sia il mito della
caverna di platone sono molto più
complicate di così
ma non è questa l'occasione per
approfondirli però qualcosa ce lo dicono
sul nostro modo di intendere oggi la
verità la verità infatti nel nostro
immaginario collettivo è un bivio un
bivio tra due strade una conduce alla
verità e l'altra conduce alla menzogna e
in questo modo di intendere la verità
non ci sono sfumature non c'è un colore
intermedio tra il blu e il rosso non c'è
una terza strada o la strada di destra o
la strada di sinistra e questo ha forma
mentis comporta chiaramente delle
conseguenze di cui dobbiamo farci carico
innanzitutto il dibattito pubblico è
diviso in modo netto tra due squadre la
squadra della verità è la squadra della
menzogna
anzi potremmo dire
entrambe le squadre sono
convinte di aver ingerito la pillola
giusta di aver preso la pillola rossa
cioè con vinte entrambe di essere di
aver tra le mani lo scettro della verità
di possedere la verità
e allora qui lo scivolamento tra il
piano della conoscenza il piano news
logico e il piano etico il piano della
morale è davvero facile cioè se siamo
divisi in due squadre i detentori della
verità i difensori della menzogna
allora siamo divisi anche tra
intelligenti e stupidi siamo divisi
anche tra amici e nemici
ancora di più siamo divisi tra buoni e
cattivi
angeli e demoni ecco allora che si
trasforma completamente il dibattito non
è più un dibattito tra posizioni diverse
è uno scontro all'ultimo sangue è uno
scontro mortale tra posizione
antitetiche l'unico scopo del dibattito
a quel punto sarà
demonizzare l'avversario demoniaco
perché perché l'avversario appunto vive
nella tenebra
e una menzogna ha scelto la pillola
sbagliata
ancora peggio l'avversario mente sapendo
di mentire
una conseguenza ancor più drammatica
però e noi che cosa facciamo noi dove ci
schieriamo noi non possiamo guardare
dagli spalti noi non possiamo
permetterci il lusso di guardare
dall'alto il colosseo dove si scontrano
i leoni
noi siamo chiamati a scendere nell'arena
to dovetti posizioni tu quale pillola
scegli tu sei nella mia squadra o sei un
mio nemico e queste domande incalzanti
le abbiamo sentite ancor più forte in
questi mesi in questi mesi in cui siamo
stati costretti a vivere costantemente
online dove il dibattito è estremamente
polarizzato
e se non ti schieri se decidi di non
scendere nell'arena se decidi di non
prendere una strada o l'altra
allora passi dei guai perché fai parte
degli ignavi fai parte degli
indifferenti
allora forse sei un codardo sei un vile
forse vuoi proteggere il tuo privilegio
frey un moralista che non vuole prendere
posizione perché ha paura e quindi siamo
stati chiamati siamo stati costretti a
scegliere il nostro spacciatore di
verità perché non dobbiamo dimenticarlo
le pillole rosse costano le pillole
rosse hanno un valore specifico nel
mercato della verità nel mercato dei
corsi on line nel mercato delle
produzioni culturali
comprare la pillola giusta vuol dire
posizionarsi e vuol dire anche
posizionarsi nel mercato
e allora cosa fare fermiamoci un attimo
che avevamo in campo una disciplina che
in teoria si occupa di verità che
abbiamo in campo la filosofia e
chiamiamo in campo la domanda che cos'è
la verità
ripetiamoci in testa questa domanda
ripercorrendo uno dei luoghi di origine
di questa domanda il vangelo di giovanni
dove ponzio lato chiede a gesù quid est
veritas che cos'è la verità
ora la filosofia si accapiglia da 2500
anni intorno a questa domanda cerca di
rispondere più i filosofi cercano di
rispondere alla domanda è più ovviamente
non trovano la risposta volendo potremmo
dire che cercare la verità è come
cercare di afferrare un gatto nero in
una stanza buia quando il gatto non c'è
ei filosofi ogni tanto si fermano e
dicono l'abbiamo preso l'abbiamo preso e
poi però sono costretti a continuare la
ricerca
però attenzione non tutto è stato vano
non tutto è stato inutile in questa
ricerca infruttuosa
ora è vero aristotele diceva la
filosofia non serve a niente
aggiungeva perché non è serva di nessuno
certo la filosofia non serve a dare
risposte chiare non serve a dare pillole
rossi a dare verità la filosofia non
insegna l'arte della risposta ma la
filosofia ci insegna un'arte ancor più
importante
l'arte della domanda l'arte dimenticata
del dubbio l'arte originaria che oggi
sarebbe così importante avere l'arte che
ci fa stare attenti a quali sono le
domande che ci poniamo allora torniamo
indietro torniamo alla domanda
analizziamo la domanda che cosa è la
verità la filosofia ci dice attenzione è
la domanda ad essere sbagliata così come
gesù non aveva risposto a ponzio pilato
gesù rimane zitto di fronte alla domanda
quid est veritas
così noi dobbiamo rimanere zitti di
fronte alla domanda che cosa è la verità
perché perché semplicemente la verità
non è una cosa la verità non è un fatto
la verità non la possiamo afferrare come
il gatto nero nella stanza buia la
verità non la possiamo inghiottire come
la pillola rossa non la possiamo
imparare a memoria come vorrebbe qualche
professore non possiamo neanche
sintetizzarla in un post su facebook o
in una storia di 15 secondi su instagram
la verità non è una cosa per questo non
possiamo rispondere alla domanda che
cosa è la verità perché la verità è un
processo la verità è un percorso è un
percorso che è destinato a rimanere in
concluso
filosofare diceva montagna è dubitare
soltanto i pazzi diceva sono risoluti e
saldi sono sicuri di avere la verità e
per questo dieci anni fa ho dato vita ad
una associazione di un festival che si
chiama popsophia la spirale che vedete
alle mie spalle è il nostro simbolo
popsophia è un laboratorio che unisce
tante filosofi tanti filosofi italiani
che unisce il pensiero critico il mondo
contemporaneo e la cultura pop e i
fenomeni che circolano nel nostro spazio
pubblico con l'obiettivo di non dare per
e pillole rosse di non dare delle verità
pret a porter preconfezionate ma con un
obiettivo forse ancora più ambizioso
cioè con l'obiettivo di mettere in
discussione mettere dei punti
interrogativi mettere dei dubbi e delle
domande che cercano di far franare le
nostre certezze che cercano di mettere
in discussione i miti ei riti del mondo
contemporaneo che possono essere oggi
forse un utile cassetta degli attrezzi
per interpretare il presente utile a
tutti e non soltanto agli addetti ai
lavori e allora per lasciarvi vorrei
proporvi un immagine alternativa della
verità un'immagine molto lontana da
quella da cui siamo partiti
siamo partiti dalla dicotomia tra giusto
e sbagliato tra bene e male tra luce e
tenebra capillo la blu e pillola rossa
invece la verità potrebbe essere pensata
in altro modo c'è stato un filosofo nel
novecento che ci ha regalato un'immagine
straordinaria di cui vorrei parlarvi per
concludere la verità ci dice heidegger è
una dura la verità è una radura la
radura e quella zona del bosco in cui
gli alberi sono più radi quella zona del
bosco in cui la luce riesce a filtrare
tra le foglie quella zona del bosco in
cui il prato
realizza un gioco di chiaroscuri
meraviglioso ecco allora che non c'è più
l'alternativa binaria destra o sinistra
luce e tenebra ma finalmente torniamo a
vedere le sfumature
torniamo al vedere la realtà così com'è
non alla luce o all'ombra ma complessa
ecco allora che soltanto se riusciremo a
pensare la verità come radura potremmo
vaccinarci da questa pandemia dei pilot
listi rossi potremmo vaccinarci dagli
spacciatori della verità potremmo
aumentare le dosi del vaccino cioè le
dosi della domanda le dosi di filosofia
le dosi del dubbio per cercare di vedere
qualcosa che ci era impedito vedere di
vedere cioè il chiaroscuro nella radura
infatti finalmente luce e ombra tornano
a dialogare a parlare a confrontarsi
grazie
[Applauso]